Charlie D'Amelio and Addison Rey are two
names that come to mind whenever tick
tock is mentioned these girls are funny
famous and talented and they've got
views for days but the more we watch
them the more we realize how eerily
similar they can be from the content
they post and their social lives to the
people they date and the tick tock errs
they chose to collaborate with keep
watching as we delve into the Battle of
the tick-tock errs Addison and Charlie's
first tick tock videos it's hard to
believe that 15-year old Charlie
D'Amelio posted her first tick tock
video on May 30th 2019 flash-forward to
today and the social-media influencer
has over 38 million followers on tick
tock alone then there's Addison Rae
Charlie's 19 year old friend and
roommate who downloaded tick-tock and
became an instant hit in July of 2019
just like Charlie Addison shot to fame
in the blink of an eye and currently has
25 million followers and Counting let's
take a look at their first tick tock
videos and compare them side-by-side
both stars got their start by
lip-syncing to popular songs with one of
their close friends Charlie and her
schoolmate recreated a phrasal meme from
one of famous Dex's tracks
whereas Addison Rae danced to a country
song while her friend strum the guitar
in the background both of these tick
tock videos are very different but they
helped Addison and Charlie become tick
tock sensations overnight Addison and
Charlie go renegade Charlie D'Amelio is
the queen of tick tock
so it's no surprise that her level of
fame surpasses Addison's still both
girls know what their followers won and
dozens of their tick tock errs have gone
on to rack in millions of views in fact
Charlie has over two billion collective
tic TOCs views although Charlie is known
for choreographing her own dances she
isn't behind the one that launched her
to fame and neither is Addison both
girls blew up on tick tock when they
danced to the song lottery renegade
perfect
this dance routine and posting it on
tick-tock became an Internet challenge
and both Addison and Charlie jumped on
the renegade bandwagon tell us whose
renegade dance is better
Addison or Charlie's for a long time
people were confused as to who created
the renegade dance and fans pointed a
finger at both Addison and Charlie but
the girls set the record straight by
giving July a Harmon the credit she
deserved
Addison Charlie and July on that up and
joined forces to bring us an epic
renegade group dance number keep
watching to vote on which rumored couple
creates the best tik toks Charlie
D'Amelio
and chase Hudson or Addison Rae and
Bryce hall doing what they do best
both Addison Rae and Charlie D'Amelio
are known for posting lip sync and
choreographed dance videos and so far
it's working for them but instead of
continuously coming up with their own
dance routines they're known for
recreating some famous videos here we
see Charlie and Addison dancing to a
popular track fight ynw meli both tik
doctors bring something new to the table
so it's hard to pinpoint which one has
the better content the girls may have a
different style but they tend to film
themselves dancing in their bedrooms or
that time when Addison danced to a duel
ito song outside of a coffee shop and
Charlie performed those same moves from
her bedroom Louis Charlie and Addison
are famous for their solo dance videos
so they're also well known for
performing group numbers but we'll get
to those later first let's find out how
these girls rose to fame while helping
their families climb on board family -
tik-tok together stay together just like
charlie Addison's family doesn't Brown
upon her love for tick-tock nope they'd
much rather join in on the fun as a
matter of fact both Addison and
Charlie's families are wildly famous on
tick-tock
Addison's dad Monty Lopez has over 1
million followers
tik-tok whereas Charlie's dad marked
Emilio has over 3 million they're used
to collaborating with stars on their
videos here we can see Monty lip-syncing
and dancing with his daughter and Jason
Derulo while Mart dances it out with
Stephen Voss aka twitch and many others
next up are their moms Cherie has over 3
million followers on Tik Tok
then there's Heidi who has over 2
million followers despite not posting
too much content both moms are known for
collaborating with their daughters in
this side-by-side we clearly see that
Addison and Shari love creating dance
videos
whereas Charlie and Heidi prefer
collaborating on comedic content if you
thought having tick-tocking parents was
more than enough think again because
both Addison entirely have siblings in
the biz we all know about Charlie's
older sister Dixie she's a height the
House member after all and she's got
over 15 million followers on Tik Tok
although Dixie loves to dance she's more
likely to post funny and relatable
content than her younger sister is when
Dixie and Charlie's started creating
tick tock videos together their
popularity blew up in just a few days
but while Charlie has an older sister
who also happens to be your best friend
Addison has two younger brothers who
still have a lot of growing up to do
sure Lucas inand so do what here in the
occasional video but they aren't nearly
as famous as their big sister Addie
luckily for Addison she's super close
friends with both D'Amelio sisters
especially Dixie who is only one year
younger than her which duo do you prefer
Dixie and Addison or Charlie and Dixie
tell us in the comments Addison and
Charlie joined the hype house type house
might be standing on its last legs but
that won't stop Charlie D'Amelio and
Addison Rae from entertaining their fans
to create her collective in LA is home
to dozens of famous tick stalkers but it
looks like Daisy Keach is bringing down
the house literally Charlie is the
youngest and most famous member of the
heights house and tons of fans have said
that the group just wouldn't be the same
without Charlie and Addison the girls
love creating fun dance videos with
their cell
tik-tok errs and when it comes to hype
house uploads the more people to better
which one of these trio dances do you
prefer
are you team charlie or team Addison
collab
Charlie and Addison never had any issues
getting noticed online before joining
the hype house they were used to posting
solo tic toc videos but that all changed
in December of 2019
now Addison and Charlie know how
important it is to collaborate with
others and they also know how vital it
can be to create group dances because
let's face it that's where the views are
at so even though Charlie and Addison
have different dance styles they're used
to joining forces with others do it for
the vine no do it for the tick-tock here
we see Charlie breaking it down with
James and Jack right but at the same
time we also see Addison and our parents
sharing the screen with little hoodie
and other hype House members clearly a
little collaboration goes a long way in
LA
chasing Charlie versus Bryce and Addison
relationships aren't exactly
straightforward in the hype house
Charlie and chase are exclusive but they
wouldn't go as far as to call each other
boyfriend and girlfriend
and then there's Addison and Bryce hall
from this way house these two were
rumoured to be dating until Addison set
the record straight during an interview
with ET in which she revealed that Bryce
was just a friend but yeah we're not too
convinced Bryce has over 4 million
followers on tick-tock whereas chase
Hudson has over 16 million Charlie and
Addison may technically be single but
they are known for posting videos with
their not so secret crushes just look at
them go which one of these couples do
you ship do you think they're dating in
real life or is it all a hoax better
together Addison and Charlie are crazy
popular tick tock stars and while people
are used to pitting them against each
other and comparing their every move
it's clear that the girls are better
together it's old news that Charlie
D'Amelio is a competitive dancer but did
you know that Addison Rae is a trained
dancer - that's
she started dancing when she was six
years old which is probably why she's
had so much success with dance and lip
sync videos the girls get some great
views when they upload tic toc videos of
them dancing together like that time
Charlie and Addison took on the popular
tik tok dance toast by de baby first
they were captured solo dancing to the
track but soon they got together to
create a toast duet despite their
popularity fans wondered if their theme
is 1-dimensional they're curious to find
out if Charlie and Addison would fade
out of the limelight if tic toc were
ever to shut down like buying one stead
and well the short answer is no social
media stars Addison will celebrate her
one-year theme in July 2020 and Charlie
will do the same in May it's hard to
believe that these two social media
stars have amassed so many followers in
so little time on top of being huge on
tick-tock the hype House members are
also big on YouTube Instagram and
snapchat absent has over 8 million
followers on insta and up to six hundred
and fifty thousand subscribers on
YouTube as for Charlie she has over 10
million followers on Instagram and
nearly 2 million YouTube subscribers
even if tik-tok were to slow down
Addison and Charlie would be just fine
there's that famous but clearly tick
tock is only getting more popular by the
second while the girls gonna have the
most videos on YouTube they do have some
similar content tick tocks most popular
dances choosing between Charlie and
Addison isn't easy to do with they're
both different in their own right
despite seeing a lot of the same dances
and videos to make choosing sides a
little easier we found a few of tick
tocks most popular dance numbers and now
it's your turn to tell us who did it
best
first there's the Fox dance which has
been covered plenty of times by numerous
tick tock errs and then there's the
cannibal dance which is just as popular
do you think it's the biggest star
Addison Rae or Charlie D'Amelio tell us
in the comments and be sure to tell us
which one of their dances is your
all-time favorite thanks for watching
give this video a big thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe for more we'll
see you next time on the things